شبح الجوع يخيم على الخرطوم مع اغلاق
المخابز بسبب عدم توفر الدقيق والاهالي
يطالبون الحكومه بالحفاظ على الماده
الغذائيه الاساسيه للسودانيين المدنيين في
السودان الذين تحولت مناطقهم الى ساحات
معارك باتوا يعيشون ظروفا صعبه مع استمرار
انقطاع الكهرباء والمياه لساعات وخروج
العديد من المستشفيات عن الخدمه
مسؤولون في قطاع الغذاء قالوا ايضا ان
المخابز اصابها الشلل وتاثرت كثيرا بسبب
اعمال العنف كما هو الحال في قطاعات اخرى
المعارك في السودان وحسب منظمات انسانيه
تسببت في تعطيل وصول الدقيق والغاز
للمخابز وقوضت حركه الاهالي الذين يترقبون
استجابه طرفي الصراع لمناشداتهم في تسهيل
وصول الطحين للمخابز
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات